bonjour et bienvenue sur guéret
simulator y est on s'excuse aujourd'hui
on se trouve sur la nouvelle mise à jour
du jeu allez pas de boutade on y va
c'est parti comme pouvait le voir déjà
notre chambre a changé et aujourd'hui
les nouveautés sont très très sale c'est
ce genre de pratique je déteste mais bon
comme le faire parce que dorian de l'est
simulator alors dieu va changer notre
culotte puis en fait chaque pilote donne
à un bonus différents et voilà c'est la
donne un bonus qu'on répand des rumeurs
allez on veut te voir te changer adhérer
au nord de changer sa mitraillette ciel
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu au moins là on va pouvoir
faire un truc extrêmement couvre déjà de
base comme on le sait instituant cette
femme qui prend cher voyez voyez
maintenant ça c'est nouveau gossip on
peut répondre finalement des rumeurs
voilà alors on va se mettre juste là
vous allez voir l'enquêté qui va venir
en ramenant vers nous
combattrons partout on excuse moi je me
cachais n'y a personne ici sommes battus
parle tout seul une fille parmi toutes
ces filles à des problèmes et
effectivement c'est elle alors on va lui
parler c'est vraiment embarrassant mais
bon ok j'ai perdu mon soutien-gorge
quelque part dans l'école et je peux je
n'arrive pas à le retrouver a donc bien
pour perdre tout soutien gorge est au
plus bas à regarder tout de suite elle
me dit me ment pas pourquoi j'ai perdu
c'est une grande histoire ok bon bref le
truc c'est que tu si tu le vois rapporte
le moins c'est parti on va les retrouver
j'ai vu que c'était le long d'une
palissade verte comme ça il doit être
par là en fait je pense qu'elle a
vraiment fait la mort des à l'école et
chez moi là bas il est regardé thatcher
sniper church [ __ ] j'suis bradley
cooper stu bradley cooper dont américain
cypher bordel ou alors je suis luc à
auxerre dans l'yonne derrière quid scoop
à toi elle a fait l'amour des à cet
arbre il ya carrément beaucoup trop de
visa vicois récupérons soutien gorge et
on va aller lui donne et à ses ultras 1
million pour elle me verrez jamais
demander à quelqu'un de trouver mon
caleçon parce que je les ai perdus quoi
y'a rien du pire elle est là avant tout
ses potes ya jeté entre soutien de
jean-louis tu l'as trouvé merci jetant
doigt une maintenant des compas avec
cette femme ellen confiance extrêmement
noir tenait bien ça c'est ce qui est
important dans cette danse est j'ai
besoin de faire une statue du mal alors
pas du tout envie de renac regardent et
attendent autant à tanger a pris en
flagrant délit et l'eau oui qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait aux jeux d'été ne pas
m'appeler quand je suis à l'école est ce
qu'on en dit très long et au talent
discret il est discrète comme j'ai dit
c'était un c'était un one shot je veux
pas leur faire quoi combien tu dis oh
non relation payante c'est ça mais si
c'est juste une fois de plus bon bah y'a
pas de problème oh non j'approuve pas ça
non plus mordelles ce soir on s'est vu
la dernière fois dans 6 août atteindre
dans la ville de ciudad ok je te vois ce
soir à [ __ ] en plus on est tellement
discret elle pouvait jamais savoir que
quelqu'un n'avait entendu quoi bon voilà
on a un gros dossier sur cette femme
elle se prostitue rare maintenant ce
qu'on va faire c'est que l vu que c'est
devenu mon ami finalement je peux lui
demander des petites faveurs voilà tu
t'en vas donc elle dit qu'il faut
respecter ça pas de souci je m'en vais
et en fait là on peut faire un truc
assez ouf on peut prendre en photo les
culottes amer je me vois en moi [ __ ]
merde mais qui me vois personne ne voit
ça apporte quoi aller je prends en photo
cette culotte hop on voit effectivement
logo là haut qui n'est pas barré et donc
j'ai une culotte photo une culotte voilà
c'est totalement pervers un bon gars non
mais j'ai rien fait les filles arrêtées
je cherche mon bac j'ai tué ma bague
quelqu'un peut m'aider s'il vous plaît
et de 4,8 arrêt total des bons gros
perdre merde ouais je vous jure c'est
pas pour le fuck the puisqu'on a besoin
des voix les a tout fait donc
logiquement d'un 4 culotte et en fait on
peut aller ici dans requête va voir
demander à quelqu un quelque chose à
mais pourquoi j'ai 0 string n'importe
quoi tu n'échapperas pas jeune femme a
en plus on t'a rendu service soit
absolument rien à dire allégera la cage
fait ça suffit wall à l'oeuvre [ __ ] à
cooking au la coke et dans la fasch kona
à luca voilà là on a eu des infos la
photographiant et maintenant ce que je
peux faire c'est très simple c'est
finalement répandre des bougon dossier
fausse manip voilà oblige possiblement
sur elle j'ai quelque chose à te dire à
propos de cet élève au mon dieu c'est
horrible mais du coup ce qui est cool
c'est quand répartissant des petits
mensonges comme ça sa réputation est
trop c'est
trop la cote à la voie en cours les gars
fin de l'école alors la fin d'école
qu'est ce qu'on fait on rentre chez soi
même
[Musique]
c'est [ __ ] j'oubliais on peut pas là
dessus et je me tiens ça fait trop peur
et moi la nouveauté extraordinaire
maintenant on est finalement chez nous
le soir dans notre chambre vous voyez ce
qu'il y à là bas est bon on peut y aller
et en fait on est sur facebook attention
sur academy a school le groupe de
l'école et on peut répondre
oui tellement d fdpc horrible si je
balance que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
que j'ai vu cette femme c'est vraiment
rude contre inter je déteste ça je les
ai vus à ses 6 août attentes je crois
c'est ça elle était en train de faire
des relations à échanges et là je le
poste en ans ça va être horrible mon
gars regardez je les marques et aux jeux
pensait l'avoir vu avec un homme plus
violents dans la ville mais je pensais
pas que c'était vraiment elle
sérieusement je pensais pas qu'il y
avait quelqu'un de ce genre dans notre
école
du coup j'aimerais voir sa réputation si
elle a été infectée ou pas moi sacré
date mais tu arriveras les gens arrivent
pour les six mois à l'école elle est où
kokoro elle est là est-ce qu'elle a des
cernes oui elle est très grande scène
reggae reisser aaron dont la complimente
on peut pas l'allèle personne mais
maintenant à vous de nous quoi on a
complimenté la personne juste derrière
elle on va au marais pourtant des
rumeurs ou lé pire alors elle fait quoi
du coup kokolo est-ce qu'elle va avec le
avec les autres encore parle au nom non
mais c'est tellement regardé l'aller ce
chemin non messieurs ory moi aussi je me
sois avec l aller on sera dans
assassin's creed on s'assoit sur les
bancs pour devenir invisible dans la
foule du coup ce jeu pour la culotte de
kokolo la même culotte que la personne
âgée a vu en échange d'argent à un
montage fait ça tellement bien et
rapidement qu à l'homme le plus efficace
du monde je suis un détecteur privé de
culotte fin de la vanne on passe à autre
chose à l a fait j'ai rien fait j'ai un
refuge à -14 dans l'habitation j'ai pris
trop chaud avant sur le toit là pendant
la pause dej on va le crier à tout le
monde on est des pires fdp du monde
about a un truc horrible suis en train
de parler sur elle ou fille alors
qu'elle est justement regarder elle est
juste l'opel sur le banc c'est horrible
et vu qu'on extrêmement faut qu on
balaie l'avant à faire un tu sais moi
les autres je les écoute pas cette
rumeur c'est sûrement faut 1 alors que
c'est moi qui l'ait lancé la rumeur fin
de la journée on se retrouve demain les
enfants pour un peu plus de rumeurs
vous n'êtes pas rimer rigoler soutenez
mois et voilà travail fait la réputation
de cette femme est maintenant 2 - sens 1
et vous allez voir ce qui va se passer
demain en arrivant en cours
oh mon dieu regardez ça c'est à table de
kokolo regarder un petit a marqué dessus
c'est affreux on veut pas plus de
prostituées six prostituées tutoie meurs
tu ferais mieux de faire attention casse
toi or là c'est horrible et du coup à
quoi elle va avoir 7 ans elle va pas
voir ça j'espère mais en fait elle vient
plus en cours carrément d'accord les
aigles ont vraiment chez les ce2 de
l'école ont ils vraiment défoncé la
pauvre quoi elle vient même pu en cours
et bat là-bas comment éliminer une
rivale dans l'intérêt du malade ce
n'est pas dans mes élèves à je trouvais
de classe pardon à lesmo millions alors
ferme la porte et on va au cd puisqu'on
est en retard oui bah l'agencé dia fin
de cette vidéo sur la dernière mise à
jour de lion doré simulator j'espère ça
vous a plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
les vidéos comme d'habitude où la
boulaye et un élèves voilà en répandant
des rumeurs totalement fausse et on
l'espionnage en entrevue dans une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir gardé
portez vous bien jazz ou le monde bis
m'habite c'est tentant
[Musique]